Film Courage: When you go back into the mainstream
population (for lack of a better word) and
you see people who come to classes or whatever
and they challenge different beliefs about
story structure or writing or the need to
take classes or whatever.
Do you see they are justified in being angry
about certain things?
Because you can look at how angry people get
over something so innocent as screenwriting
and you say “What’s the justification
for this?”
You can take it or leave it.
Take what you like, leave the rest kind of
thing.
Some people become so dogmatic about certain
things and it almost becomes a fight about
religion when it’s just screenwriting.
Alan Watt, Author, Screenwriter and Founder
of L.A. Writers' Lab: Right well those kind
of people don’t stay very long in a class.
And I also have no desire to argue with people
or…that’s not true.
My interest as a writing teacher is to get
to the truth.
So if someone is arguing with me about something
or is staunchly holding a position, my question
is “Is that true?
Is what you’re saying true?
Let’s explore that.
Let’s examine it.”
Because I have no dog in this race.
I’m not dogmatic at all.
I have been teaching a long time.
I’ve been writing a long time.
I’ve got a method that I’m teaching people
but I don’t know if I would actually call
it a method…process that I’m teaching
but yeah I don’t get into fights with people
about writing.
It’s like you believe that and you’re
so staunchly holding that point of view well
then good.
How’s it working for you?
Is it helping you with your writing?
If it is then great, and if it’s not then…
I see it a lot with writing teachers.
I think there are a lot of writing teachers
who are…it’s almost like they’ve got
to secure their sort of place in the world
issuing everything that isn’t what they
teach and that can be I’ve seen it a lot
where the latest thing is that some writing
teachers say the three-act structure is dead
it’s, it’s remedial, it’s not going
to…it’s going to squash any creativity.
The problem with that is that they don’t
understand what the three-act structure is
because the three-act structure has nothing
to do with plotting in my opinion and unfortunately
a lot of story structure is taught by story
analysts who are sort of brilliant left brain-ers
and are really adept at deconstructing a masterpiece
and sort of the implication is that now we’ve
deconstructed this you should go off and write
your masterpiece.
And while there’s tremendous amount of value
in studying film theory or…film theory because
it’s deconstructing CASABLANCA or CITIZEN
KANE is going to help you understand how a
story was built to some degree.
But it’s not teach you process.
It’s not going to teach you to organize
your ideas.
When you look at a movie like CASABLANCA and
you think about the Epstein Brothers writing
or structuring this movie I’m interested
in the process.
I’m interested in how did somebody come
to write this.
In other words you can sort of like just because
you deconstruct something so it’s like vivisection
you can’t take something not living and
look at all of its existing parts and then
reanimate it.
It’s not going to come back to life.
So just because you can break down this thing
into its sort of separate parts doesn’t
mean you are going to uncover the mystery
of what the thing actually is.
In other words story structure is really the
DNA of your protagonists transformation.
Does that make sense?
Story structure is really the DNA of your
protagonists transformation.
It’s not in the midpoint there should be
a reversal.
Like I don’t even know what that means?
You hear it all the time with these story
analysts that there should be a reversal.
What the hell does that mean?
Does IT’S A WONDERFUL LIFE have a reversal?
That’s where Mr. Potter offers Jimmy Stewart
a job and Jimmy Stewart says no.
I don’t know?
I think of story structure as not a conceptual
model something you can figure out but it’s
more of a experiential model.
In other words you protagonist goes through
a series of experiences that lead to a transformation.
And I think of story structure as an immutable
paradigm for a spiritual transformation.
It’s immutable, it never changes.
But that doesn’t make it…that doesn’t
limit your creativity.
That actually paradoxically opens your creativity.
In other words when you really understand
what story structure is it moves you beyond
your limited imagination of what your story
is.
I always tell my writers your idea of your
story is not the whole story.
It’s not that it’s incorrect, it’s that
it’s incomplete.
And so if you were to distill story structure
to three words it would be Desire - Surrender
- Transformation.
Show me any story, you are going to have a
character that wants something (desire).
You are going to have a character that lets
go of the meaning they made out of their goal
(surrender).
You are going to have a character that experiences
transformation in other words a shift in perception.
A reframing of their relationship to their
goal.
Show me a story that doesn’t have that and
I’ll show you a story that doesn’t work
or is really experimental okay.
But that’s when people…it’s happens
not when I teach so much as if I do a lecture
to a bunch of people there’s always sort
of the contrarian, the person who is like
“You know I don’t agree with that.”
And I’m like “That’s great, let’s
talk about that.”
But it’s usually about something that they
are trying to work out with themselves and
it’s not really…I don’t know?
It’s usually that they are looking for some
kind of fight rather than they are actually
sincerely interested in deepening their process.